[Music]
i know you're back to work though
because we saw that hashtag uh what is
it more than more than 10 or 10 years
we're in our 11th season if you could
give some advice to younger kaylee 11
years ago what would you say to her um
get used to those stairs in the
apartment set because they're gonna get
a lot harder to climb by season eight
nine ten eleven oh and also like my eyes
are getting worse so you're gonna have a
wedding checked when you're 21 not you
kaylee
spilling major big bang theory secrets
at the end of season 10 sheldon was down
on one knee to amy
are we gonna have a wedding i hope so
you know at least an engagement oh oh
your guys are in everything that you
want to happen in the opening will
happen so i'll tell you that you'll be
very happy in the opening but you know
there's always going to be problems to
ensue you know and i don't know what the
writers are planning but i'm sure if
it's a wedding it'll be somehow probably
star trek themed or something hysterical
i don't know that for a fact but if i
had to assume i would think so don't you
want sheldon to i mean i think the
hilarity comes in the marriage i mean
he's crazy enough but don't you want him
to oh absolutely i think you know
actually what makes him so he's so
unique but i think he's actually going
to end up being a very good husband
because he's such a one-woman man he and
and same with amy i think they're going
to be a very committed couple what is
going on with penny are we what are you
guys going to do what is she going to do
this is
wasted most of the time penny is really
good at drinking wine
it's one of her favorite pastimes
um i wish there was a calorie cup on the
set of big bang so then i would know
exactly what she was drinking but um
yeah she you know she's working and her
and leonard have a very cute little
relationship but i think we're gonna
probably focus on the um sheldon amy
situation for at least a couple episodes
yeah the 31 year old is also teaming up
with panera bread what are they doing
they've brought out this cup that has
the amount of calories every drink these
new iced teas they have it tells you
when you pour soda how many calories are
in it yeah and actually how many
spoonfuls of sugar are in it we're all
super healthy especially in hollywood
and all of this stuff but you drink a
soda and you ruin it really fast this
cup is awesome and i'm here to to give
my promotion for it today
[Music]